A code of ethics doesn't solve.
It might be a guide,
but at the end of the day,
individuals have to make their own
ethical decisions every time they face a
question in a quandary.
I've had have had editors who have stood
by me and defended me when I pissed off
somebody in the company,
and I've also have editors who come
after me and said,
oh,
you can't do that because it's going to
piss off somebody and no code was going
to deal with that.
I think that I've learned new ethics in
the blog world.
I line,
that's not to say that they're better.
That's not to say that I rejected the
ethics of journalism than I learned
before.
I don't.
I teach them,
but I've learned an ethic of
transparency online and my blog now,
I tell you the stock I owned,
who I vote for,
and all kinds of things,
things that I wouldn't have done back in
the days when I was a full time
reporter,
but I think are very important now.
So I've learned an ethic of
transparency.
I've learned a new ethic of the
correction on blogs.
If we make a mistake,
we don't erase it.
We cross it out,
we fess up,
we admitted was there,
and if we don't do that very quickly,
we're going to lose credibility.
I've learned an ethic of openness and
collaboration.
When I'm working on a story,
I'm working on an idea.
I asked my readers to help me and they
are very generous.
If I just ask,
those are new ethics that I've learned
online that I think old media can learn
from.
At the same time,
there are ethics of the old world that
live forever,
that are immutable,
a fairness,
accuracy of balance,
not objectivity,
but I think those are things that we can
do a better job of helping to teach from
old media for our experience.